I want you to play through all of your
reactions during the movie oh yes
Langston Belton here with a very special
Earth's Mightiest Show bonus we are here
in New York City for an awesome employee
screening of Marvel Studios Avengers
endgame the people from the house of
ideas that work with the characters that
you and I know and love are about to
check out this massive cinematic event
before anybody I got my ticket it's
about to start so let's go inside hey
hey hey no no you can't bring that in
here no listen you heard the Russo
brothers you don't spoil the end game
okay I'm gonna check out the movie I'll
tell you how it was I promise hang out
here please hang out here don't don't
hang out here go yeah
[Music]
how are you feeling right now
overwhelmed
perfect entrances perfect character
moments amazing team ups Easter eggs it
had it all
man I am fried I am like riding an
emotional roller coaster but also a
physical one my pulse is racing it's
crazy it was way too short I really
wanted to go on longer I don't know how
you can talk about this movie without
spoiling moments that don't spoil it
they team up I started crying I looked
across and I saw you crying I saw you
out of your chair crying and that's when
I was like oh no this is this is real
this is happening for all of us the
movie starts to no good the movie
starting and then as soon as it starts
like oh yeah this is sad and then sort
of like dips in and out throughout the
whole time see like old friends new
friends look at this this is great being
able to see them come so far and to have
them acknowledge how far they've come
was one of my favorite parts nobody else
is gonna build 23 movies that build this
way now can't be down again certainly
not in my lifetime
this movie is incredible everyone here
is incredible it gets the Marvel
employee stamp of approval and you gotta
go see Marvel Studios avengers endgame
in theaters right now go see it I'm
Langston and this is Marvel your
universe mightiest show go watch full
episodes of Earth's Mightiest show now
on Marvel calm Marvel social media and
on the official Earth's Mightiest show
Facebook page yeah where you can get all
of our latest episodes plus the behind
the scenes photos from our set Marvel
lose hilarious comic panels and La Fleur
this is Marvel your universe
[Music]